lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en la relación entre dos
variables y pensar en cómo se vería esta
relación en una gráfica digamos que aquí
estoy dibujando dos ejes en el eje
horizontal está el precio de un producto
y en el eje vertical la demanda de ese
producto demanda del producto y sólo voy
a dibujar el primer cuadrante de estos
ejes asumiendo que el precio va a ser
positivo y la demanda también va a ser
positiva
qué va a pasar cuando un precio es muy
bajo si el precio es bajo podemos asumir
que muchas personas van a querer comprar
ese producto por el precio barato si el
precio es barato entonces la demanda va
a ser muy alta si el precio fuera cero
la demanda sería altísima aquí lo
podemos poner demanda alta y el precio
cero
si el precio aumentará un poco pues
podríamos pensar que la demanda
disminuiría un poco
si el precio vuelve a aumentar un
poquito más la demanda va a ser menor
entonces vamos a dibujarlo aquí si el
precio aumentará más pues habría menos
personas que podrían comprarlo o pagar
ese precio así que la demanda va a ir
disminuyendo si el precio fuera muy muy
muy grande la demanda sería muy pequeña
y podemos dibujar este comportamiento
como esta línea magenta esta línea que
va hacia abajo así que esto es la
gráfica de la demanda con respecto al
precio puede ser curva hacia abajo o
curva hacia arriba pero más o menos es
esta la idea si ustedes ven esta curva
como la línea magenta
si el precio aumenta pues qué pasa con
la demanda aquí va aumentando el precio
y voy a ver el valor de la demanda pues
va disminuyendo ahora vamos a ver otro
escenario vamos a imaginar la demanda de
de un terreno y vamos a poner aquí abajo
en el eje horizontal la población de una
región y en el eje vertical va a estar
la demanda por terreno por terreno
y no hay gente en esta área si la
población es muy muy pequeña tendiendo a
cero nadie va a querer comprar terreno
ahí cuando la población es cero la
demanda demanda por terreno será cero
también conforme aumenta la población la
demanda por el terreno va a aumentar si
hay mucha gente en esa área muchas
personas van a estar queriendo comprar
terrenos para vivir así que la gráfica
de relación de la demanda de terreno con
respecto a la población va a ser así
aunque puede variar un poquito pero la
idea es que si ustedes ven una gráfica
así ya ustedes les preguntan cuando
aumenta la población qué pasa con la
demanda de terreno a bueno pues aumenta
aquí lo estamos viendo vemos que este
valor de población que va aumentando y
vemos otro valor de la demanda que
corresponde y vemos que está aumentando
a diferencia del ejemplo anterior en el
que al aumentar el precio disminuye la
demanda ahora voy a dibujar un ejemplo
más general en el que no voy a estar
dando ejemplos específicos pero
si yo tengo este diagrama en el eje
horizontal tengo x en el vertical ayer y
les preguntan qué pasa con la variable
yen cuando x se incrementa
bueno aquí elijo un punto en x veo el
correspondiente y si aumento este valor
de x voy a ver cuál es el valor de ley
correspondiente y en este caso veo que
está aumentando así que en este caso yo
va a aumentar mientras x se incrementa y
también se incrementa aquí lo escribimos
cuando x se incrementa y se incrementa
aquí vamos a escribir otro ejemplo
genérico en el eje horizontal tengo a en
el eje vertical tengo a b y esta es la
gráfica esta línea que pasa cuando
incrementa bueno en este caso hago lo
mismo elige un valor de amd veo el valor
correspondiente en b y si aumentó el
valor de a hacia la derecha que pasa con
el valor de b b un punto de a hacia la
derecha y veo que en este punto el valor
de b es menor
que cuando aumenta a b va a disminuir oa
decrementar se entonces para que tengan
la idea general cuando ven este tipo de
gráfica en la que x y aumentan la línea
de la gráfica va a tener una pendiente
hacia arriba cuando la x se incrementa
la incrementa también por lo que está
pendiente se va a elevar ahora en el
otro caso cuando tenemos una variable
que aumenta y la otra decremento se dice
que la pendiente va hacia abajo como
pueden ver está pendiente disminuye